this dude still alive is not a dude Nura
dude this this is a man by Handsome
Charlotte Russe oh you want me to go
Jamie Foxx on this one Oh everybody put
on
[Music]
here we are on the set of Avengers I've
been lucky enough along with other
guardians of the galaxy to join up with
the Avengers and be here and get an
opportunity to save the world is in my
Choong Avenger now as well I don't know
maybe like a third string of ender yeah
was one of the founding members yeah
thank you it's been this witnessing of
like people's lives growing and changing
it's been a really cool experience
working with Lizzy has been really
really awesome and I think there is
something very powerful about being able
to play women who do heroic things and
those women are so awesome so we've had
a really good time you know out of all
the people that I've had the good
fortune to work with these two
particular guys and the triumvirate that
we formed together
it's very special friendship and
decade-plus of time together
hanging out with everyone on the set is
one of the best parts of this job
actually because it does have this kind
of large extended family feel I had a
bit of a bucket of someone's worth
practice I thought he'd be good fun I'm
proven completely wrong in that front he
was odd Lluis and boring and not
particularly funny well at first Blanche
it's hard to know what to make a
Cumberbatch and then the more time I
spent with him on and off set I just
kind of infatuated with this guy I was
thinking you know the journey that
Robert Downey jr. has made he's the
Godfather of all this is literally been
the adventure of a lifetime I get a
little misty thinking about it so you
know I lucked out
this is it it's always leave us
bringing Avengers infinity war to
audiences is an incredible road Joan I
have traveled with Marvel big wide shots
and we're gonna expand your tribe it's
been a marathon it's actually been a
double marathon because we shot both
Avengers three and four back-to-back in
a one year time frame so it's about as
Herculean a task I think as there is in
filmmaking
the last thing that you guys are playing
was really good it's a distress signal
Rach if someone could be dying but it
has been I think the most fulfilling
creative endeavor we've ever experienced
we walked forward 10 feet straight on
the straight to camera there's been a
teen films building up to this and we
wanted the audience to go on a journey
and have an emotional catharsis in a
response to the situations that these
characters get put in and ultimately the
choices that they make which are
heartbreaking it should cost Joe and I
we've counted ourselves as fans long
long before we ever became filmmakers in
the MCU these movies would be nothing
without the passion that the fans bring
to them we feel there's a really special
kinship with the fandom and it drives us
to ever greater heights and storytelling
you
[Music]
you